هذا المسجد الذي وقع فيه الانفجار
حدث يوم الجمعة
أثناء صلاة العصر أه هذا الاثنين
وهو في منطقة مجمع الشرطة في
مدينة بيشافا لذا فإن غالبية
المصلين في ذلك المسجد كانوا
في الواقع من ضباط إنفاذ القانون ويبدو الأمر
كما لو كان هناك  شعور
ديجافو لأهالي بيشافار لأنه في
العام الماضي فقط كان هناك
هجوم مماثل في عاموس في
مدينة بيشابارا حيث قتل أكثر من 60
شخصًا قيل لنا أنه لا
يزال هناك أشخاص عالقون في الأنقاض  من
هذا الطحلب لأن السقف بالكامل سقط
عليه ، لذا فإن جهود الإنقاذ لا تزال
جارية الآن الظلام في باكستان
وهذا حدث في فترة ما بعد الظهر لذا فقد
مرت عدة ساعات منذ وقوع الانفجار نفسه
وهناك تحقيق
جار أه رئيس الوزراء في
بيان قال ذلك  إنه تفجير انتحاري
أخبرنا به مسؤولو الشرطة
أنه من المحتمل أن يكون تفجيرًا انتحاريًا
حدث في الشهرين الماضيين ، وعلى
الأقل منذ سقوط كابول في عام
2021 في صيف عام 2021 ،
كانت هناك زيادة في هجمات المتشددين  في
باكستان وخاصة في شمال
باكستان ، إسلامبا ، العاصمة حيث كنت
في حالة تأهب قصوى خلال
الأسبوعين الماضيين ، كانت هناك
محاولة هجوم انتحاري في قلب
العاصمة في نهاية
ديسمبر فقط.  منذ أسبوعين ، كان
هناك هذا الشعور المتزايد بالخوف
في باكستان ، وهناك فهم مفاده
أن الوضع الذي شهد في
العامين الماضيين تحسنًا ملحوظًا في الوضع الأمني ​​في
باكستان
لم يعد هو نفسه كما قلت
سابقًا ، إنه شعور  من deja vu
لأهالي peshava الذين عانوا بالفعل
العديد من مثل هذه الهجمات في مدينتهم
الأجنبية